padam padam padam pas mon cas salut joly
et françois salut qu'à séjour qui
émergea vous savez je sois en pleine
forme
la vie est belle aujourd'hui je vais
aller rendre une petite visite à mes
amis les la faire et j'en reviens dans
un instant abdallah à tout à l'heure
kazemi il aurait fallu le lui dire
françois honoré coûte saluera gâcher sa
bonne humeur
non il faisait un tel plaisir de sa
visite chez ses amis les la peur ratti
va savoir ça il va tout de suite vouloir
rentrer chez lui va tout compte fait je
me demande si c'est pas une bonne
occasion de lui apprendre à se dominer
que veux tu dire beaucoup de julie tout
simplement que nous sommes tous habitués
à vivre au contact de gens qui nous
plaisent pas toujours c'est pas une
raison pour se sauver à chaque fois
non il faut que casimir soient polis
avec la demoiselle futur caressant mais
qu'est ce que tu fais moi rien je range
mon panier pour aller chercher des
bonbons acidulés ou pas au jury tu
donnes tu n'as pas route comprend pas ce
que tu veux dire aussi c'est du tu
comprends très bien ce que je veux dire
julie regarde il te reste encore deux
beaucoup plein de bons - si des noms tu
cherches tout simplement une bonne
excuse pour ne pas rencontrer les
futaies vous avez raison mais alors sol
vous avez découvert la vérité vous aviez
oublié chers amis que je suis le plus
brun dit équipe du monde
julie je me demande vraiment ce que tu
as contre et mademoiselle fut-elle n'est
pas si désagréable que ça
non pas du tout mais c'est sa poignée
mas qui me fait peur si on refuse de lui
serrer la main
elle se vexe et si on accepte on a deux
doigts écrasés à chaque fois que je lis
je sais mais aujourd'hui il faut
absolument faire un effort qu elle nous
a écrit à tous les trois pour nous dire
qu'ils venaient et qu'elle avait une
surprise pour nous alors imagine sa
déception la peau aussi lorsqu'elle
arrive je suis tout seul bon et vh1
reste mais en attendant je vais faire
des exercices de musculation
c'est très bien ça mais moi il me reste
la nouvelle annoncée casimir de mauvais
fais le avec patins qu'est ce que tu
fais avec tes doigts julie je m'entraîne
pour serrer la main de mademoiselle
futech tout à l'heure mois viendra vous
comme leçon de tact c'est réussi
excuse-moi françois si parler
machinalement
bon eh bien je suis malade alors je vais
aller me coucher
les émirs casimir fsi mais non je
t'assure j'ai très mal au ventre
casimir du exagère à chaque fois qu'il
ya quelque chose qui te déplaît tu
prétends que tu as mal au ventre
non non non je t'assure je suis mal à
douala où j'ai mangé un hommage quasi
mis au pas ce que je t'avais préparer à
super jlouli boulga ah bon - super duo
bulgare regarde je me sens tout de suite
beaucoup mieux là je ne sais pas un
d'entre eux c'est très très faim gênant
bien une seconde casimir une seconde du
[ __ ] gloubiboulga si tu acceptes
d'attendre mademoiselle fuite est avec
nous et ensuite de la saluer poliment
quelle honte françois me faire de
chantage à moi en pondre au casimir us
qui meurent de faim
on sait pas c'est pas honnête tu aurais
pu faire appel à mon à mon courage et ma
loyauté à mon sens du devoir ou à mon
courage indomptable est notable et tu
aurais accepté non et on échange de
gloubiboulga j'accepte les émirs je
crois que c'est toi qui devrait avoir
honte
tiens cabinet attend gloubiboulga
fataliste si pour le manger
bonjour nous elle fit est françois
serrons-nous larmes
[Musique]
on y suit une poignée de maxis agréable
s'étaient massés au bord de l'iss avant
nous sommes avec plaisir et de mes os
mais c'est faux pas eu mal du tout il
faut vous dire que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé pour arriver à ça et c'est
grâce à monsieur du snop qui m'a
recommandé auprès de monsieur jacques
gazeaux je vous savez le professeur de
maintien le résultat est étonnant c'est
grâce à vous françois si j'ai appris
l'importance d'avoir de bons amis nous
en sommes ravis mais je ne vois pas les
petits kangourous enfin des pistes vous
parlez je pense de casimir bien sûr il
va arriver dans un instant on attend
mieux
j'avais peur de l'avoir ratée puis parce
qu'en venant je me suis arrêté pour
serrer la main à un enfant pour
m'entraîner une dernière fois ils
avaient les mains couvertes de confiture
ans et j'ai horreur d'avoir les mains
poisseuses et alors je suis retourné
chez moi vous me l'avez les maquettes
oui j'arrive mademoiselle futé j'arrive
un bon jour c'est moi faux mais qu'est
ce que vous avez sur os mais qu'est ce
que t'as sûreté mais bon ce n'est rien
ce n'est juste un peu de bananes
écrasées à confiture de fraises en
parallèle tout ce qu'il faut pour faire
un bon gros bulgares ont métier les
mains tout poil un petit
romney
[Musique]